I think we know enough about
shorting now that we can start
thinking about whether it's a
good or bad thing to have in
financial markets.
And what I've done here is
I've drawn a hypothetical
stock chart for a company.
This time right here.
This is the price
of the company.
And let's just say that this is
a chart in a universe that
doesn't have short
sellers in it.
So this is all-- here a lot of
people are buying the stock,
then over here some people,
maybe they get freaked out or
whatever, they start selling.
And then more people buy.
So demands a little higher
than supply, so
the price goes up.
And that just generally
drives the volatility.
Now in a short selling world,
what would happen?
Let's let's think about two
scenarios, a short seller who
makes money, and a short
seller who loses money.
So a short seller
making money.
What would a short seller making
money have to do if
this is the stock chart.
Obviously, they don't see the
stock chart beyond the day
that they're actually making
the trade, but in order to
make money they'll actually--
they'll have to short at the
local peaks.
And they would have to
cover their shorts
at the local minimum.
So a good short seller-- or
you can even say a perfect
short seller would maybe short
here-- let me make it a
different color so you can see
where he's acting-- would
short here and then
cover there.
And he would make that much
money on that move.
And then he would wait a little
bit, wait for the stock
to get expensive again
in his mind.
And he would short here, and
then he would cover here.
This would kind of be--
obviously it's very unlikely
that someone could so well pick
tops and bottoms. But
let's say they're just really
good at their analysis and
figuring out market psychology
and things like that.
And they would just
keep doing it.
They would short here
and cover here.
What would that actually
do to the stock?
The green line was a
reality where you
had no short sellers.
Now if all of a sudden you
allowed short selling, and
they had these guys come into
the market who know how to
make money shorting.
He's shorting up here.
So what would shorting do?
Shorting is you're borrowing
the stock and selling it.
So he's creating extra supply
for the stock, right?
So what he would be doing at
this point, by shorting, is he
would actually be lowering
the price at this point.
So let me draw the curve.
So if there's a bunch of short
sellers acting in this range,
it would actually
lower the peak.
Because you have a bunch--
you have some
more aggregate sellers.
So the price wouldn't
go as high.
And then on the other hand,
these short sellers have to
cover right here, right?
They're going to cover
their position.
So at the low point you have
more aggregate buyers covering
a short position, is just you're
buying the stock to pay
it back, because you borrowed
it earlier.
So here you would have more
aggregate buyers.
And then at this point, once
again you have more aggregate
sellers, so the price
won't go as high.
You have more aggregate buyers
here, because the short
sellers need to cover, so the
price won't go as low.
And so forth and so on.
And the bottom line is, a short
seller who's making
money on the stock market, so
they're shorting the stock at
peaks and covering the stock
at troughs, is actually
reducing the volatility
of the stock.
And that's good for everybody.
That's good for the company's
management.
That's good for the actual
shareholders of the company.
And obviously it's good for the
short sellers because they
are actually making money.
And this is actually true for
anyone making money in the
stock market.
That they're reducing
volatility.
What is a long-- just a regular
investor-- or I guess
you could call them a trader
since they're buying and
selling-- a regular trader would
make money by buying
here and selling here.
So really a regular trader
is not any different.
A regular long trader is no
different than a short seller,
it's just the order in which
they're buying or selling.
But anyone making money is
buying at low points and
selling at high points.
And anyone doing that is
helping to reduce the
volatility in the stock.
And even if you're a long term
buy and hold player, you would
rather sit and hold a stock--
you would rather be a holder
of a stock that does this,
than a holder of a
stock that does this.
Now there are a lot of players
both on-- you could call them
traders because they're buying
and selling on a regular
basis-- that aren't kind
of doing this.
Maybe they're piling on the
shorts at a low point and
they're causing the stock
to go down even more.
And then, when the stock starts
to move up they get
scared and they buy it, and
it causes the stock to
move up even more.
And it increases the volatility
of the stock.
But these guys are being
penalized because they're
losing money.
The people who sell at low
points and then buy at high
points, and increase
the volatility,
they're getting killed.
They're falling every day.
So it's not like you
have to create some
penalty for those guys.
Their penalty is that
they're just bad
traders, they're bad investors.
And they're just going
to lose their shirts.
So if you're assuming that none
of these traders in any
way manipulating the markets
or spreading false rumors.
Anyone making money on a stock,
as long as they're not
manipulating it, on either the
short or the long side, is
actually a net asset
for the stock.
That they're actually reducing
the volatility
of the stock price.
I guess another thing to think
about and this is just from
a-- it's good.
They're reducing the volatility,
so from that point
sorting doesn't seem too
bad, for me, or in
general to the market.
But another way to think about
it is, kind of where are all
the incentives in the markets?
Who has an incentive to be
positive on a stock?
And who has an incentive to
be a negative on a stock?
Or to scrutinize a stocks?
Well, the biggest, I guess
cheerleaders, for a stock, and
it depends on their degree of
kind of credibility or ethics,
would be the company's
management, right?
These are people-- it would
be company's management.
These are people who obviously
run the company, but they have
the best transparency into the
financials of a company, and
they tend to be shareholders
of the company or get
compensated based on
how the stock does.
So these guys have every
incentive to be positive.
And, as we've seen multiple
examples of, whether you're
talking about the investment
banks, or Enron, or Accenture,
they'll often kind of hide the
truth when things get bad.
So these guys are definitely big
time positive on stocks.
Then, let's see, who are the
other players or the
influencers on financial
markets?
Well, a big one is the
financial press.
And I'll write it out here so we
can have a discussion about
whether they are pumpers of
stock or whether they tend to
be more-- whether they tend
to scrutinize things
a little bit more.
An important thing to think
about with the financial
press, and next time you watch
CNBC-- and I don't want to
just pick on them-- is how
do they make money?
Do they make money by
finding things that
are wrong with companies?
Do they make money by
making you money?
No, they make money
by selling ads.
And then the next question,
obviously, is who are they
selling ads to?
Are they selling ads for mops?
Are they selling ads
for bicycles?
No, they're selling ads to
financial services companies.
So people who want to manage
your wealth, stock brokers,
mutual fund companies, anyone
who can advertise.
And this is key, too, because--
I don't know, you're
probably not aware of it but
hedge funds can't advertise,
so they're not consumers of the
financial-- or they're not
customers of the financial
press.
The only people who are
customers of the financial
press are money managers,
financial planners, and things
like that-- brokers,
mutual funds.
And all of these guys benefit
when stock markets go up.
Obviously mutual fund managers
will-- they tend to be long
only, so they only want
things to go up.
Stock brokers-- you might say,
oh you know, a stock broker
can advise you to go long or
short and they just care about
how many transactions
you make.
But in general, more and more
people put money into the
stock market in rising
markets.
In a market like you're seeing
right now over the last year,
people are pulling out-- you
could say oh, maybe people
aren't doing more transactions,
but the general
net effect is, people
are pulling
money out of the markets.
So when they're pulling money
out of the markets, brokers
are getting less transactions,
they're managing less money.
And that's also true of
the money managers.
And there's also just another
ancillary side effect, is when
markets go down and people
become less excited about the
stock market, people stop
watching CNBC and CNNfn.
And so even those few ads that
are for mops and for bicycles
and for cars will get
fewer viewers.
So in general the financial
press, at least in my opinion,
is squarely in this camp.
And then we can talk more, you
know, sell side analysts.
You've probably heard the term
sell side and buy side.
But sell side analysts are the
analysts that work for the
major brokerages and investment
banks, who publish
those reports that you see in
those ratings, a buy rating on
IBM, or whatever.
And the reason why they call
them sell side analysts is
because they work for the people
who are essentially, on
some level, selling-- you could
either view them as they
often offer securities, or they
offer financial services
to, often the companies
themselves, or to potential
acquirers of the companies.
Or they're selling their
services-- I mean, usually--
they're brokerage services, so
they're trying to get people
to transact, they're actually
brokers on some level.
But clearly these guys, their
incentive, since their
customer tends to be the
management of companies, is to
be very, very, very positive.
And you should say oh, there
are other people who, their
whole job is to scrutinize
these people.
Like, the government.
But if you think about it once
again, the government likes a
rising stock market.
It takes-- when people's 401k's
are rising, the economy
does better, the government
doesn't have to worry as much
about other types of social
benefits, and unemployment,
and things like that.
So in general, and if you want
to be more, I guess, if you
want to be more critical of the
government, you could also
say that they are, to some
degree, very close to the
management of these firms and
to financial companies.
And to some degree, these guys
have significant clout in
terms of lobbyists-- and, well
actually, I would even say the
bankers, too.
They have significant clout in
terms of lobbying, and just
access to government,
generally.
And government drives the
regulators, so these guys are
also on the positive camp.
And then finally you have
the ratings agencies.
And the ratings agencies mainly
operate in the debt world.
And we'll talk more
about that.
But, if you can scrutinize a
company on the debt level, and
you say oh wow, this company
really isn't that good,
they're not going to be
able pay off its debt.
That kills the stock.
But once again you have to
realize that the rating
agencies are also paid by the
bankers, so the rating
agencies are also-- have the
incentive to kind of not see
things when things are bad.
So out of everyone in the
financial services, or the
financial world, that we've
talked about right now, they
all benefit when stocks
continue to go up.
Even when they go up beyond what
they really should go up.
And even if they all kind of
know that things are a little
bit too expensive.
Or this management team might
be a little shady, or they
might be covering
up something.
None of these people
really have an
incentive to expose it.
And the only people who do
are the short sellers.
These are the only people who
really have, arguably the
sophistication and the time and
the monetary incentive to
really look and scrutinize
what management is doing.
To really look in the books
and kind of put a puzzle
together, or put a bunch of
pieces together to come to the
conclusion, wait, the numbers
that management is spouting
really don't add up.
And because of x, y and z,
this company really is
overvalued.
So to a large degree they are
kind of on society's side in
preventing management from kind
of being overly bullish.
And I don't want to sound like
someone who just broadly is
defending short sellers.
There is a class of short
sellers that I think would be
bad, and that's the people who
are spreading false rumors,
and being market manipulators.
So there's just the
general market
manipulation, or rumor mongering.
And that definitely is bad, and
to some degree, if you can
show someone is doing that,
there should be some type of
penalty for doing it.
But even there, and just it in
my experience participating in
public markets, if I had to
pick-- if I had to pick
between the left side of that
chart, between this side of
this charge and this side of
this chart-- and if I had to
say who does spread
false information
when it does get spread?
I think often times management
is a little bit more guilty of
it than the short sellers.
In fact there's very few times
that I've seen where the short
sellers are-- there's some
negative thesis on the stock
and where it really comes out
to be completely untrue.
Although, there are examples,
and those short sellers, I
don't think are really in the
mainstream Anyway, I don't
want to meander too much.
I realize that this video
has already gotten long.
But I thought it's a nice,
useful discussion to maybe
think a little bit about whether
short selling really
is all that bad, even if you
are a long investor.